in this video i'm gonna explain what you
can expect to see
in attack on titan season four and we're
going to be doing this without giving
away
any spoilers you may think that sounds
impossible but
what i'm gonna do is give a very generic
overview of the things we can expect
without going into any spoilery details
season 4 is of course going to be the
final season of attack on titan
so be sure to hit that sub button as i
will be doing more videos as the season
goes on
okay so as you probably guessed from the
trailer attack on titan season 4 will
introduce us to
a whole new cast of characters from the
outside world we found out in season 3
that humanity was not exclusively
confined to the walls as
as we previously believed and yeah
everyone outside the walls
pretty much hates everyone inside the
walls the nation of mali
is where most of the new characters will
be coming from and season four will show
you how the people living there
have been indoctrinated to believe that
you know all the people on the island
are just
devils as we found out in season three
people on the island are part of the
eldian race which is why they are able
to turn into titans
whereas normal people cannot turn into
titans so that's pretty much the main
distinction between
aldeans and regular people during season
4 we'll get to see how eldians
outside of the island are being treated
around the world
and we'll also see how eldians are used
by the nation of mali
the mali storyline will give us proper
backstories for characters we already
know
which will really enhance our
understanding of why they acted the way
they did
in seasons two and three also the
motivations of certain new characters
will become
very understandable but that probably
won't stop you from hating them but you
know
you'll understand their point of view
along the way we'll discover the truth
about the great titan war
that caused the aldians to be trapped
behind the walls in the first place
and will also see the ninth and final
titan shifter
this was briefly shown in the trailers
and i won't say the name
but the mystery surrounding who has that
titan will will be very interesting
something else you'll notice from the
trailer is that eren mikasa armin and
pretty much everyone else
they all look older and that's because
they are there has been a time skip
during the time that has passed between
seasons three and four
the eldians on the island have learnt
certain things that have changed erin's
perspective on who should live or die
in my opinion i think season 4 eren will
be the best aaron we've seen
because he's just way cooler and he
makes way more calculated decisions
than he's ever done before the origin of
the titans themselves will also be
explained
as we'll finally get the truth as to how
they exist in the first place
on top of that new titan abilities will
be seen for the first time
even for titans that we've already seen
before so they'll be doing new things
that we didn't know they could do
aaron's connection to another character
in this series will be a crucial factor
in the decisions that everyone makes
and as the season progresses will be
really interesting for us to kind of
figure out who is telling the truth
beyond being a show about titans season
4 is equally a series about politics
as we see the politics of the island and
the politics of the outside world
being big factors in decisions that
people make these political
disagreements are based on
self-preservation revenge racism
and a lack of trust that will ultimately
decide the fate of humanity
as much as i would like to say more i
feel that that is enough for this
overview of what to expect but let me
know if you want to see
more attack on titan videos in the
comments thanks for watching and
until the next one peace out